the Cold War and the fall of the wall
only occurred 20 years ago it's very
very recent but it's very very important
perhaps one of the most important
historical events of our age
once the past becomes history it's
harder and harder to get a grasp on so
we needed a resource in order to collect
the materials in order to have a place
for serious investigation venda is a
german word that means transformation or
change it's been used to describe this
incredible shift from the end of
communism and the former East Bloc the
fall of the Berlin Wall
and the transition to in a sense a new
world we want to be a museum that rather
than tells people how it was we want to
provide the stimulation and we want to
inspire people to come here and find
their own path in their own way and
ultimately we find that that's really
the only way people are going to
discover the essence of what the Cold
War was a lot of materials we get up
some former border guards secret police
agents and a lot of times we have no
idea what it's even gonna be until it
gets here here this would have been a
normal briefcase don't look like all the
others except that when you see this oh
here if you look they're sort of a
reflective lens there it's because it is
a lens this used to spread across here
to conceal a camera and so much of this
material has not yet been processed
we have film audio pictures archives
still bundled and sealed as they were on
the last days when the Wall fell this is
a bt9 border guard tower but actually
when you take the top off it's a vodka
bottle the most engaging most
interesting time periods in history are
those that show us the full range of the
human condition from the very worst to
the very best I can't think of another
time that shows this as dramatically as
during this time of transformation in
the late 1980s when the Berlin wall
collapsed you have a situation where
these border guards who spent basically
their entire lives defending this wall
then all of a sudden it's gone and to be
able to investigate what was going
through their mind is a very unique
position for us to be in we have the log
books from the border guards of what was
going on minute by minute when the Wall
fell and you have border guards that
react in totally different ways you have
some that just say okay this is it and
they just walk home and never come back
again and you have those that actually
continue to show up every day for work
for the next five to six months and
continue to fill in these logbook
reports about illegal border crossings
and before it was you know one illegal
attempt a month or whatever and they
would end up for hiding things like
3,000 people tried to cross cross the
border illegally today without a visa I
mean there are swarms and swarms of
people going through the border here I
mean the idea that a border even existed
anymore was crazy the walnut Wilshire
project was a project in which we
brought over ten segments of the
original Berlin wall and we brought it
here to LA to commemorate the 20th
anniversary of the fall of the wall we
invited street artists who are people
that often not only observe society but
society is observing them there's this
also way of looking at the world which
Street artists have that we can relate
to and of course the Berlin wall itself
was the ultimate concrete canvas we
wanted to really engage la and beyond to
say that this is an idea that's much
much bigger than Berlin or the Cold War
what history can give the very best
thing that it can give is a sense of
self and I think if this museum can give
a sense of self and the end the time
period in which we live in today by
reflecting on the past I think we've
achieved our mission
you